a popular kids show quite possibly the
most popular kids show in the world is
apparently trying to turn your child
into a tutu wearing Mama denying
genderbending dancer as evidenced by
this recently viral
clip know you you love to get up and
dance how about you break out those
moves for your two biggest
[Music]
fans
if you're not sure what to choose think
about all the things you like to
do just be you just be me yep when
you're trying to decide think about all
the things you like to
do just be you just be
me believe that clip was dug up by the
Twitter account end wokeness I'm not
sure I will ever forgive end wokeness
for digging that up up why shouldn't
kids shows depict little boys wearing
tutos and dancing for the pleasure of
homosexual men who have somehow gained
custody of them huh come on man it's
2023 sure until the mid to late 20th
century anyone who ever considered
creating a scene like that even for
adults would have been ostracized from
polite society and likely prosecuted but
it's
2023 standards have changed get with the
program this is just what kids are
watching these
days this is what kids are watching
these days when I say cocoa melon is
popular I mean it's the third biggest
Channel on YouTube ever I mean 169
million subscribers on YouTube it's the
second most viewed Channel on YouTube
I'm talking 172 billion views billion
with a B this channel has distribution
deals with Netflix Roku and who ULU it's
been able to rack up all of those views
according to a New York Times profile
through a single-minded strategy to keep
kids attention liberal friends of mine
who let their kids watch CoCo melon have
described it as crack for
kids I have not put Coco melon on my on
for my kids for for a few reasons one
because I love them two because the show
has always struck me is extremely
annoying and three because I just assume
that any anything modern and popular and
praised by the libs is poison now we
have proof that's why we launched our
own kids platform bent key if you're
already a dailywire member then you've
already got it and if you're not and you
have kids I strongly recommend that you
get it now but even if you don't at the
very least I strongly recommend that you
do not put your kids in front of Coco
melon when the indoctrination is subtle
it's easy to blame the content producers
when the leftist indoctrination is this
overt if we keep putting it on for for
our kids then we have no one to blame
but ourselves I'm Michael nolles this is
the Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show new
scientific study just dropped shows that
you are destroying the world by
breathing so you know the solution
that's what just that's just what the
scientists say you know what you have to
do you know what else is destroying the
world according to these people when
cows
flatulate uh so they they want you to
give up all your meat of course and they
want you to eat grass or something and
become a bunny rabbit but I don't
recommend that I recommend you eat the
best meat out there with good ranchers
right now go to goodranchers.com use
promo code nolles are you looking for a
memorable last minute gift try good
ranchers your place for standout gifts
this Christmas season While others will
be regifting mugs and candles they got
earlier this time last year you can
bestow juicy delicious burgers crispy
bacon tender chicken and phenomenal
steak upon your Secret Santa plus good
ranchers gift boxes are 15% off and as
low as 99 bucks until Christmas give a
stocking stuffer they will cherish with
a gift card to America's best meat or
give a gift that keeps on grilling with
a monthly subscription it's the best out
there the best in the business I don't
understand how the prices are so low the
quality is higher than anything you're
going to find anywhere else give the
gift of good ranchers you make meals
easy you support hundreds of American
Farms and you keep generations of flavor
alive best of all you're giving a gift
that is truly delicious that you can be
proud to give save an extra 15% on every
order with code NES KW at
goodranchers.com get free shipping plus
100% satisfaction guarantee what are you
waiting for go to goodranchers.com find
all your gifts this year code nolles
kwes save a bonus 15% today during their
last minute gifting sale no stress no
risk just America's best meat delivered
with good ranchers I can already hear
the objection to my criticism of Coco
melon they're going to say the libs of
course they're going to say Michael
what's wrong with a kid being
himself oh what's wrong with a nice
supportive loving family encouraging a
kid to be himself H just be
yourself
I I guess what's wrong is the assumption
that that makes about human nature which
is that there is this true
self at the core of an onion we just
need to peel away the layers of society
and norms and standards and practice and
morality and tradition and ritual we
need to peel away all those layers and
then we will get to the true core of the
self and the true core for that little
boy is wearing tutus and dancing for a
couple of homosexuals that's the true
that's his real identity once you peel
away the layers of Oppression in society
that's not actually how human nature
works it's not actually how identity
works this is so Insidious because what
really lies at the core of human
behavior certain things are genetic
predispositions certain things are just
woven into the fabric of human nature
but a lot of human behavior and
especially human desire comes from
imitation we imitate the people around
us we're like chimpanzees in this way we
just we we mimic people we are mimetic
creatures the baby learns to talk by
copying his mommy and daddy one hopes he
has a mommy and daddy the baby learns to
talk the the parents are speaking and
then the baby say mama dad Da Mama Mama
Mama Mama and then you say other words
you know applesauce applesauce right and
that they learn to copy Cy you if you've
ever been around children if you've ever
had children of your own especially
you'll know that kids are like little
sponges every word you say they're going
to start copying every little behavior
that you you do even every unconscious
Behavior you move your eyebrow in a
certain way you you walk in a certain
way they're going to copy that we are
mimetic and we are mimetic when it comes
to our desires as well I mentioned this
on the show yesterday in a different
context the reason people want the Rolex
watch is not because they know anything
about how the Watch Works it's not
because know anything really about the
history of the company or the mechanics
of a of watch gears it's because other
people want the Rolex watch other people
who they admire and respect like the
Rolex watch so they want it too the
reason you want your neighbor's wife is
not cuz she's Helen of Troy it's not
because she's the hottest woman ever
it's because your neighbor wants her and
so our our our desire not only do we
mimic the speech and behavior of others
we even mimic their
desires so the way way that a kid
becomes his true self is not just by is
not certainly not by peeling away the
layers of learned behavior it's by
acculturating him the way he becomes his
true self is by educating him it's by
how he's raised so if a kid is raised by
a lumberjack and his traditional wife in
the mountains of who knows where
somewhere in the Western United States
and they've got really traditional Val
vales and the dad goes out and chops
wood and the mom churns butter and I
don't know I'm probably getting into
some kind of fairy tale Fable of a
traditional life but that kid is going
to be more likely to go chop wood or if
it's a girl more likely to churn butter
this we end if a if a child is raised by
a couple of homosexual men who purchased
the child from scientists and
impoverished women in the third world
through IVF and surrogacy then that kid
is more likely to to mimic their
behavior
and if a kid is raised to be told that
it is oppressive for a boy to play with
gi. Joe and it's wonderful and
liberating for a boy to wear a tutu and
dance for the pleasure of his fathers
quote unquote he's going to do that too
and if a kid is raised watching that
absolutely degenerate cartoon then the
kid is more likely to mimic those
behaviors as well we think of this in a
really visceral way and we say you are
what you eat if you eat a lot of bad
food you're going to feel bad if you're
just eating fast food all the time
you're going to get get overweight and
Bloated you're just going to feel
lethargic and bad well the same is true
it's especially true when it comes to
our minds and our souls the more bad
stuff we take in the worse we're going
to feel the more it's going to twist our
desires and our sense of identity and
ultimately our soul is what we're really
talking about and this is quite clear
when we talk
about porn on the Internet that's
probably clearest when we talk about
porn it's even worse than Coco melon and
we we had ardan young a young journalist
on who had conducted an investigation
through sound investigations at PornHub
a couple of weeks ago well she's got
more to her investigation now she went
undercover and spoke to not just the
senior writers at the parent company of
PornHub which is who she nabbed
previously but now she's speaking to a
technical product manager at this
company uh the company was called
mindgeek but of course the company is
just so disreputable so despicable that
they have to keep changing their name
because because like the euphemism
treadmill bad connotations just glom on
naturally to whatever this company is
called so it used to be called the
company itself is called PornHub and
there are other related porn sites the
parent company was called mindgeek now I
think it's called Alo but here we have
Mike Farley technical product manager at
mindgeek according to his social media
and unlike the previous senior staff at
pornhub's parent company that ardan
interviewed this this guy is not totally
gung-ho on the product he actually
expresses some real reservations about
it so many people perray porn is like
liberating
liberating I don't know if it's I think
it's just the easy way
out I think you're taking the easy way
up and like I don't think anybody like
watches porn and then like feels good
about themselves themselves after it's
not really something that you're just
like yeah
I'm like it's not it's like it's like
ecstasy to like what the am I doing it's
like an
addiction well I definitely think we an
addiction is that's for
sure yeah no I I don't know I don't
think it's like a positive thing in
general even like Jordan de I know that
he says like
the there's not many studies on it
there's not a lot of like we don't
really know the
implications you've seen like thousands
the hottest girls on Earth naked right
like in your brain like your brain
thinks you've seen them in person like
there's no difference right like
visually you saw it and I think like
that there's no way that that's like
normal like that can't be normal I can't
be healthy I like this guy I guess maybe
the reason he's got a more normal and
reasonable perspective on this is he's
not one of the writers unlike those
other two guys who said yeah we're
trying to slip in all sorts of weird
especially deviant into the so-called
straight porn and then that way we're
going to convert the customer to a new
product
and those guys truly just seem like
demons this guy doesn't seem like a
demon he's working for a very very evil
company but he's the technical product
manager he strikes me as just a normal
Tech guy right and I guess he maybe he
didn't get a job at Boeing or something
he didn't he didn't get a job at Nasa so
okay he's going to take the job at the
porn company but at least he gets it
everything that guy just said is totally
true which leads me to an important rule
for life he mentioned Jordan Peterson
I've got it I've got a rule for life
this is the 13th rule for Life we'll get
to it in one second first
though when you want access to a good
technological platform that can help you
have a good relation with the opposite
sex you got to check out higher Bond
right now go to higher bond.com if you
are single you've probably seen or heard
about all the insane dating apps out
there but what if I told you there was a
dating app that actually cared about
your morals your biblical values higher
bond is the new Christian dating app
built to be safer less stressful and
more Christ centered higher bond is
completely different than anything else
out there there's no addictive swiping
the focus is truly on quality over
quantity it is designed to form lasting
marriages higher bond is veteran owned
by a husband and wife looking to change
the way Christian singles meet online
it's no secret that left-wing media and
big Tech are against companies like
higher bond in fact Fact one of the
major tech companies is preventing
higher bond from running ads on their
platform their ad team took a screenshot
of high Bond's website highlighted the
parts that said Christian in yellow and
said this is why we're not going to run
your ads it it's almost unbelievable
except we see these kinds of things so
often now our society our country need
what higher bond is providing if you're
single you got to check out High
bond.com sign up before New Year's Eve
and get 3 months of higher Bond premium
absolutely free higher bond.com today
new rule for life just dropped brought
to you by the technical product manager
at mindgeek pornh hubs parent company
Mike Farley and the rule is
this don't let your behavior stop you
from acknowledging the truth don't
become a captive to your own bad
behavior this guy unlike the other staff
at PornHub who ardan interviewed
undercover this guy guy is clearly
struggling with the immorality of his
job this guy clearly recognizes
something is wrong with this company
with our modern culture he listens to
Jordan Peterson for goodness sake okay
he's obviously in some way on the right
track but he still works for this big
porn company and he's helping to promote
something that's very evil and that
according to his own admission is not
healthy for people so what's he going to
do what a lot of people do this this to
some degree describes all of us we know
that there's a right thing to do but we
do the wrong thing
what do we do in that circumstance well
we only have two options we can
either admit that what we're doing is
wrong and feel some degree of Shame and
either live in that shame as Hypocrites
or try to better ourselves and try to
improve even though we're going to
stumble or we can deny the truth that we
know in favor of the
behavior and most people I think most
people here maybe not here not in the
creme deem Michael no show audience but
most people in general will do the lad
if they're doing a behavior that they
come to realize is is wrong or immoral
not healthy they will deny the truth
that they have reasonably arrived at in
order to justify the behavior and and in
part some of the reason they'll do that
is they'll say well if I ackn I someone
working for a porn
company if I acknowledge that porn is
bad then I would be a hypocrite or I'd
have to quit my job and I can't quit my
job I got a mortgage payment you know
and I look it's a complicated world it's
not black and white there's all sorts of
Shades of Gray in the Middle come on man
I look it's maybe it's not the H but I
hey anyway all that moral philosophies
and that's above my pay grade I'm just
going to go out and get my bag you know
make some money and we'll worry about I
don't know it's not that bad right
that's that's what most people do and
who am I to lecture people on this this
I am working at a porn company and ah I
can't be that bad therefore no the good
thing to do though the right thing to do
is when your reason has arrived at
something at a conclusion that's
obviously true and your behavior doesn't
jive with
that even if you can't change the
behavior yet even if you're just so
habituated to this behavior that you you
can't you feel totally powerless to
change it at least acknowledge the truth
don't deny the truth to justify your own
bad behavior at least acknowledge the
truth and simply by acknowledging the
truth you will begin to start to turn
those Wheels to of your desire to start
to maybe kind of make a change in your
behavior that guy could probably do
it for most of these guys you feel you
feel kind of bad for them that they're
getting caught on camera and they're
going to lose their jobs and for but you
don't really feel that bad for them
because they're doing terrible things
and for this guy though I'm glad he's
going to lose his job because he wants
to lose his job on some degree on some
level rather he he wants to he knows
it's bad he knows it's not healthy he's
a tech guy I'm sure he can get another
job somewhere
else he could do it good I hope he loses
his job it'd be good for him I don't
hope he loses his job because I think
he's a bad guy I think he's kind of a
good
guy glad he got caught now you are
seeing a
principle a version of this principle
applied in the presidential race there
are a lot of people who hate Donald
Trump shocking to hear I know there were
a lot of people even in the Republican
Party who hate Donald Trump there are a
lot of people who worked for Donald
Trump who hate Donald Trump and still
when Colorado Supreme Court came out and
said Trump cannot appear on the ballot
because we are going to in an
unprecedented way radically reinterpret
a Civil War era provision of the
Constitution designed to stop
Confederate generals from taking over
the government we're going to interpret
that to say that the mean orange man
from New York can't be president again
even Bill bar former Trump attorney
general who has been a huge Trump critic
came out and said it's totally bogus as
you know I I strongly oppose Donald
Trump for the Republican nomination but
uh I think that this case is is legally
wrong and
untenable uh and I think this kind of
action of stretching the law taking
these hyper aggressive positions to try
to uh knock Trump out of the race uh are
counterproductive they backfire as you
know uh he he uh feeds on griev just
like a fire feeds on oxygen and this is
going to end up as a grievance that
helps them to deprive somebody of the
right to hold public office requires due
process it requires an adjudication of
two core issues one was there an
Insurrection uh did the public
disturbance rise to the level of an
Insurrection and and second what was the
role of the of the individual in there
was it engagement did they do something
to break their oath of office those are
those are complicated facts and this was
denied due process uh it was a 5-day
hearing uh there was no jury it was
before the judge I think if they take it
up they're going to slap it down very
quickly and I hope they do take it up
quickly and slap it down because
otherwise he could be left off the
ballot uh in in this primary so bar
absolutely totally right here bar is not
the only one John Bolton former National
Security adviser to Donald Trump Bolton
has been a huge Trump critic of late
he's certainly not going to support
Trump in 2024 John Bolton same thing
very serious lawyer educated man
Washington operator he says this
Colorado ruling completely nuts I think
it's completely misplaced I think this
this Colorado Supreme Court decision is
badly wrong for multiple reasons number
one the the 14th Amendment provides that
Congress can pass legislation to carry
uh its Provisions into effect which
Congress has done on many aspects has
not put anything with respect to section
three on the books uh since just after
the Civil War uh second the the idea
that uh 50 different state courts can
can decide a question involving the
highest elective office in the executive
branch interpreting the Federal
Constitution as to what constitutes an
Insurrection against the federal
government uh is is incoherent and I
think undoubtedly the Supreme Court's
going to have to clear that up I be
willing to bet a small amount of money
here that the Supreme Court uh if it
gets to the merits of this if it has to
uh will reverse there's there's no other
logical way you can uh apply this and
and it would seow chaos in elections as
far as the eye could see Colorado
Supreme Court has done something that I
didn't think possible the Colorado
Supreme Court has gotten Bill bar and
John Bolton to support Donald Trump
again not to support him they still
don't like him they don't want to be to
be president again but to be on his side
of this argument I think the Colorado
Supreme Court has United the Republican
party here no Republican other than the
most
absurd shill for the Democrats you know
Court Jester conservative types like Liz
Cheney I haven't even heard heroine on
this nobody seriously can argue this is
a coherent decision we got to protect
ourselves we got to protect our country
you've got to protect your body that's
why you got to check out Pac Shield
right now head on over to Pac shield.com
promo code NS whether you are a parent a
frequent traveler or simply an
individual seeking enhanced personal
safety you need to check out pack Shield
Pac Shield is a ballistic insert that
fits into backpacks messenger bags and
briefcases the insert meets the National
Institute of justice and 3A standards to
stop a 44 magnum pack Shield comes in a
variety of sizes and colors plus it
weighs less than most textbooks and
laptops so it can be easily transferred
from bag to bag I have some pack Shields
great thing about them is no one can
tell I have it on my person they are
extremely lightweight inconspicuous I
love knowing that I and you and anyone
who gets it can be protected with pack
Shield it is easier to keep your head
down I know it it's easier to not think
about potential threats that you could
encounter in public life you got to
think about those things you got to be
prepared pack Shield gives me peace of
mind pack Shield should never be used
for any reason other than personal
defense so pack some protection and some
peace of mind with pack Shield check
them out for yourself at PAC shield.com
promo code nles kwes for 20% off that is
Pak shield.com promo code nles kwes for
20% off today you've heard me say that
kids content is indoctrinating your kids
with radical left-wing propaganda you
may have heard me say that earlier in
this show it's only getting worse the
New York Times attacked our bent key
show chip chill for having a quote
weirdly present father who teaches quote
lessons about dead white people those
dead white people include George
Washington Neil Armstrong and Benjamin
Franklin Coco melon obviously it's got a
bazilian views on YouTube they're
they're introducing multiple dads and
encouraging their kid to wear tutus and
and dance around for them Peppa Pig
Blues Clues Muppet Babies and more
continue to aggressively push radical
leftist propaganda onto our children at
the daily wire we don't just complain
about the problem we create Solutions
that's why we've invested millions of
dollars into making bent key a platform
for kids entertainment that Pro protects
kids from the most radical ideas of
today Ben key has great content your
kids are going to love it don't take my
word for it starting today you can try
Ben key for free Merry Christmas just
download the app or go to Bent key.com
use code unlock to start your free
14-day trial give your kids content they
will love this holiday season on a
platform you can trust join the bent key
family today spread the word start your
free trial encourage everyone else you
know to do the same unlock the new
adventure and kids entertainment today
bent key.com code unlock that code that
you need to start your 14-day free trial
is
unlock bill far and John
Bolton don't like Trump but they're
coming to his defense what are the
candidates doing in the 2024
presidential primary V ramaswami has
just pledged that if this decision is
not reversed he will pull his name off
the ballot in Colorado as well they have
just tried to Bar president Trump from
the Colorado ballot using an
unconstitutional maneuver that is a
bastardization of the 14th Amendment to
our US Constitution this was a provision
section three that was designed to Bar
Confederate members people switch to the
Confederacy from actually being able to
serve that's very different than what's
at issue here to say the least this is a
hollowed out husk of what the country
was built on the basic principle that we
the people select our leadership not the
unelected elite class in the back of
Palace Halls that's Old World Europe not
the United States that's why I'm making
a pledge today that I will withdraw I
pledge to withdraw from the Colorado GOP
Primary ballot unless and until TR
Trump's name is
restored and I demand that Ronda sanis
and Chris Christie and Nikki Haley do
the same thing or else these Republicans
are simply complicit in this
unconstitutional attack on the way we
conduct our constitutional
republic very clever political maneuver
because it puts the other geop
candidates on defense and I don't think
this is just a cynical Ploy I think it's
an admirable thing to do
I think that we cannot allow the
Democrats to decide who the GOP nominee
is I think we cannot
allow elected and appointed officials in
the states who are big Libs to so
subvert our sacred democracy that we
hear so much about that they prevent
people from voting for the popular
candidate for
president I think it's it's admirable it
would send a strong message I've heard
some conserv a say that it would be
completely uh self-undermining for the
other GOP candidates to pull off the
ballot in the Colorado primary I don't
understand that I think it would be a
very strong statement of Republican
Unity to say first of all Colorado is
not going to choose the GOP nominee
Colorado primary is not for a very long
time it's not going to be decisive and
it sends a statement to say this is a
this is a bogus process this is a Banana
Republic kind of maneuver here and we
are not going to dignify it with our
presence on the
ballots won't matter now a lot of the
candidates don't want to do that because
they want as many delegates as they can
possibly get to try to make some kind of
challenge to Trump which seems totally
implausible at this point Trump
continues to totally dominate the field
everywhere throughout the entire country
and every state so I it's not a huge
cost to the candidates other than it's
an acknowledgement that Trump is the
presumptive nominee a lot of them don't
want to to make that acknowledgement but
I think it would be a very strong
political maneuver for Republicans to do
this to pull off of the ballot and to
say no we yes we're going to lose some
delegates I guess it's relatively low
cost because it's Colorado but more
importantly we're going to send a
message this election process is being
rigged by the Democrats this is a fake
election process you guys are are
rigging it in such a way that the
popular candidate will not be able to
Garner the votes of the people who want
to vote for him this is bogus we will
not go along with it and I think the
Republicans who leave their names on the
ballot are going to be sending the
opposite message they're going to say
well you know too bad for you Trump hey
Democrats please let me stick around
I'll be nice it's very strong very
strong move now Ronda santis gives a
good argument in the opposite direction
fellow GOP 2024 presidential candidate
VC ramaswami saying he will remove
himself from the Colorado ballot unless
Trump's eligibility is restored would
you do the same no I think that's just
playing into the left um I think the
case will will get overturned by the
Supreme Court but I've qualified for all
the ballots I'm competing in all the
states and I'm going to accumulate the
delegates necessary that's the whole
name of the game in this situation but I
do anticipate that that decision was
political and will get reversed so that
last part there DeSantis is 100%
right if I were a Gambling Man which I'm
not but if I were a Gambling Man I would
put money on the Supreme Court
overruling this decision it's just
Preposterous it's a Preposterous
decision so what desand is is saying is
hold on I'm not I'm not going to pull my
name off the ballot in Colorado and then
this decision gets reversed by the
Supreme Court and then Trump's on the
ballot and I'm not I'm not going to do
that that's crazy why would I ever do
that fair enough reasoning I think the
reasoning there is is
tight but desantis's stance looks bad
politically even the way he's saying it
looks bad he looks defensive he looks
irritated he looks peeved goes no I'm
not come on no I'm not doing that I'm
going to be I've qualified for the
ballots I'm going to be on the ballots
no and it's going to get overturned
anyway it's not that big a deal come on
Move Along move along it doesn't look
good it it is a big deal even if it does
get overturned and I agree it probably
will be overturned it's a big deal that
the Democrats are using their political
power their their power in elected and
appointed office to totally subvert our
democracy which they purport to love so
much to prohibit people from voting on a
ballot for the popular candidate who
happens to be a former president who
happens to be the front runner in the
GOP field by a country mile that's a big
deal we haven't seen that ever actually
but they're going to reinterpret a post
Civil War provision of the Constitution
intended to stop Confederates from
taking over the government 150 years
later to stop the the mean orange man
from being on the ballot that's a big
deal okay and to to downplay that to
undermine it looks like you're fine with
this rigging it looks like you're fine
with this fraudulent electoral system
and
and this has been a problem with the
disantis campaign from day one which is
that the guy is super smart the guy is
super effective the guy is very
admirable in so many ways but he he just
doesn't seem to have the pizzazz on the
campaign Trail to to communicate that he
has what George will once referred to as
the Charisma of confidence of competence
he is he's very competent in office but
you also need the Charisma of Charisma
when you're on the trail and you also
need to be able to speak to broader
political movements and issues it's not
just nuts and bolts wonery it's not just
going in there and unclogging the pipes
if you're a plumber there there needs to
be a broader political Vision if you're
going to lead a broader political
movement and V is seizing on that right
now I'm not suggesting it's going to
boost his numbers above to santis or
anything like that but I just think vake
understands the significance of that
moment and he is capitalizing on it much
more than santis is even if his
reasoning on the court process and and
how the ballot is ultimately going to
look is totally
sound now you know one thing that unites
VI and Ronda
santis there's a few things they're
Republicans they're guys they're running
for president they're both graduates of
Harvard
University the Harvard undergrad
actually they're both graduates of Yale
too the was Harvard undergrad and Yale
law school and Ronda santis was Yale
undergrad and Harvard Law School that's
kind of weird and so they they both I
guess will have a bit of Shame at uh the
the president of one of their
institutions Harvard Under Fire because
their president Claudine gay
uh defended calls for genocide against
the Jews is as requiring a little bit of
context you know I'm not quite sure if
it's harassment and also then she was
caught plagiarizing I guess basically
everything she's ever written including
thank you notes for Christmas gifts you
know she's just PL plagiarized
everything and uh now we found out that
the Harvard
president uh once created a quote task
force on visual culture and signage to
make white men less visible at Harvard
we found this out thanks to Chris
rufo who is on a Jihad against claudi
and gay and might might still end up
getting her fired he pointed out that
after the George Floyd riots during the
George Floyd riots uh gay commissioned
this task force that released a series
of recommendations for engaging with the
quote historical Reckoning with racial
Injustice and the recommendations
included a mandate to change quote
spaces whose visual culture is dominated
by homogeneous portraiture of white men
homogeneous you know all those white
guys look the same you know you know how
all those black guys look the same oh
hold on you're not allowed to say that
oh man that' be you'd be totally
canceled if you said that but now those
white guys they're all just they're all
just stupid evil white guys I hate them
they're the worst aren't they I hate
those white guys well anyway that's what
the Harvard president thinks she said we
need to get rid of all these pictures of
white men she said that administrators
needed to refresh the walls of annenburg
hall because it quote prominently
displayed a series of 23 portraits none
of which depict women and all but three
of which depict white men and we hate
these white men it doesn't say who the
white men are so they usually leave out
who the white men are cuz they're some
of the most accomplished people ever in
history that's why they have their
portraits on the wall but but they don't
want to get into that they just say we
hate Whitey we hate the white guys get
rid of them we need to refresh things
because of these stale disgusting awful
white men this woman is awful this woman
Claud Dean gay this president of Harvard
is just cartoonishly awful she goes
before Congress first of all there's the
Pome on Israel probably the largest Pome
ever you know certainly in recent
history and uh the the Hamas runs in
totally uh unexpected attack and her
first response is silence her first
response is while the Harvard students
are are defending Hamas is silence then
because of that she and the the pen upen
president get dragged before Congress
and she and the pen lady both say that
well you know calls for genocide against
the Jews it doesn't necessarily
constitute harassment you know when you
really think about it and this and that
and this and that so the pen lady gets
fired because she's white and we hate
white people remember white people are
evil they're terrible so she gets fired
instantly Claudine gay though is not
white she also hates white people
apparently she wants to refresh Society
by getting rid of the white people so
she gets to stay in office because if
you fire her she would be uh you would
be racist
rather but then we found on top of that
thanks to Chris rufo and Aon sarum the
journalist that this woman has
plagiarized everything from her doctor
dissertation in school to I think she
has a total of 11 academic
Publications actual Scholars have 11
academic Publications before they leave
graduate school okay but Claudine gay
who is manifestly not an actual
scholar has 11 total in her entire
career and she plagiarized those
including the acknowledgments in her
academic Publications such as they are
so then they get her on that but they
still don't want to fire her because
it'd be to fire her go fire another
Karen at another IB League school but
you can't fire Claudine gay and now we
find out that she undertook an active
campaign to get rid of the white guys on
campus is it any Wonder then the numbers
are in numbers don't lie that Harvard's
early admission applications have
dropped to a 4-year low Harvard's early
admission apps are down
177% now when you want to go to an
institution known as a university that
will actually teach you true things you
got to check out prageru right now go to
prageru.com a majority of gen Z supports
left-wing policies like open borders and
socialism if we don't reach them and
change their minds the country we know
and love will be lost forever prageru is
a leading nonprofit when it comes to
influencing young people prageru's
educational entertaining pro-american
videos meet young people where they are
online and open their minds to the truth
but they need your help go to
prageru.com make a tax deductible
donation whatever you give right now
will be tripled and have three times the
impact donate 10 bucks it triples to 30
give a 100 bucks it triples to 300
prageru is 100% free to everyone no fees
no subscriptions they don't rely on ads
or clickbait headlines contrary to what
the libs say prageru is not funded by a
handful of billionaires it's funded by
people just like you in order to keep
making great content reaching millions
and changing Minds Prager you needs your
help head on over right now to
prageru.com today maybe check out the
book club while you're there maybe check
out the 5minute videos I I've done a lot
of work with prageru we we still have a
show over there now so make sure that
you give be as generous as you can
prageru.com my favorite comment
yesterday is from Razzle 07 who says
Colorado Citizens should mask up cases
of trump derangement syndrome resurging
they are they are and you're going to
need to stay way more than six feet away
from people if you it's
extremely
contagious Harvard having a real-time
recruiting students it's weird isn't it
Harvard supposed to be one of if not the
most prestigious universities in the
country fouryear low 177% down on early
admissions what's that about it can't be
about the plagiarism Scandal actually
because the deadline for early action
was November 1st and the plagiarism
Scandal didn't break until a couple
weeks ago it can't be even the
Congressional testimony the
Congressional testimony was
after the
deadline what it was though I think was
was related to the October 7th Pome
because after that attack you had all of
the Harvard groups something like two
dozen Harvard student groups voicing
support for the Palestine Liberation
movement and for Hamas and that just
doesn't look good it created a real
wedge in the Democrat Party The Wedge
being that Elite Democrats older
Democrats support Israel younger
Democrats activist Democrats support
Palestine
Liberation there's not a lot of room for
reconciliation there that is a proper
wedge
and th those scandals especially now
imagine if the early application
deadline were later probably the the
drop would be even more signif ific
those scandals are actually hurting the
university 17% down is is rough so what
do we do I think we follow Chris rufo's
lead Chris rufo is a very very
effective groman political activist
meaning he's very he's a very smart guy
he's a good Think Tank scholar he's a
good journalist but what he's really
really good at
is emulating the tax itics of the
political left the radicals Antonio
gromi Herbert maruza the new left of the
1960s he can emulate their tactics in a
just way for the principles of the right
and he's better at doing that than just
about anybody there are very few people
who come even close to Chris rufo and
that's what he's doing here he's trying
to get the Harvard president and this is
the kind of specificity that we need
okay we're not going to take down every
university in the United States the
universities are the epicenter of
leftist power the universities are
where radical leftism really came alive
in the
1960s they they provide the sin aures
for the radical leftist activists the
downstream effects of that are massive
because all of the political Elites go
to these schools so it's it's huge and
if we could gut those universities it
would be the biggest power grab by
conservatives in Generations but we're
not going to get rid of all of them
right away we're not going to retake
those universities right away we're not
even going to going to knock the ivy
league
away but we might get Harvard we might
just get
Harvard if we can just persuade enough
students not to apply to Harvard and
maybe they go to Yale maybe they go to
Stanford maybe I get a kind of a kick
out of it even though Yale is extremely
leftwing too and probably wants to
resend my degree every day of the week
uh I kind of get a kick out of it
because I've rooted against Harvard for
a long time and now actually Harvard
might go down but forget about all those
schools are are extreme ex left wing
Stanford Yale Princeton Cornell all of
them but if you can get the students to
go from Harvard to the peer schools you
can really weaken Harvard and then you
drive you keep pushing on the president
Scandal and you get the President to
resign in disgrace that further hits the
Harvard reputation and then you point
out to the donors that you got two dozen
Harvard student groups Marching for
Hamas that's really going to hurt the
donors that's re that's really going to
hurt the donations coming into Harvard
and then you've got a three-pronged
attack that seriously weakens what is
the the symbol of prestigious Elite
Education in the United States a
stronghold of the left and that's a
political
win you're you're not going to take down
every woke Corporation at a time you're
going to take down budlight if that okay
that's your chance go you get one of
them you know even Target we tried to
take down Target didn't really work we
did take down budlight got to keep up
the pressure on budlight too budlight is
not the only company that's embraced the
radical LGBT element of people the
agenda far from they all have but
budlight did it in in the most egregious
way that they gave us the biggest
opening we took them down we and we took
a scalp a corporate scalp that's what we
got to do here with Harvard keep it up
now speaking of Science and scholarship
peer-reviewed study I teased it
yesterday uh this comes from the public
library of science Sciences Journal
P investigated uh greenhouse gas
emissions of methane and nitrous oxide
in human breath which allegedly
contribute to global warming so what's
the conclusion that we would draw from
this
paper global warming is really bad
threatens to kill us
all your breathing contributes to global
warming
therefore you got to stop
breathing that's the only reasonable
conclusion you can draw if you accept
those two
premises and this was always the end of
it the end of the climate religion the
cult has always been anti-human
isn't it coincidental how everything we
hear every piece of practical advice
that we get from the climate religion
people
always reduces Humanity always
diminishes Humanity always says hey you
got to have fewer children having
children is bad for the world hey you
got to eat less when you eat it's bad
for the EnV hey you got you have to have
less culture no meat no no moving around
no building things you can't build
things that's bad for the environment so
let you have to you have to have less
culture you need to live in smaller
spaces no nice big houses you got to
live in little tiny cages like rats yeah
otherwise the world is going to end yeah
you got you can't you can't have
electricity you can't fuel things you
can't build and dig and grow and create
all of that's over oh and by the way now
you got to kill yourself you have to
kill yourself cuz other otherwise you're
going to die if we it reminds me of one
of those early South Park episodes where
the crazy Hunter Jimbo he says now
listen boys we got to go kill all these
deer we got to use Bazookas and all
sorts of crazy guns and we have to kill
them because we got to thin out the herd
or else they'll die and there actually
is a good argument for thinning out the
herd when it when it pertains to animals
not to human beings but but it this
argument was being made in a satirical
way because at at a very literal
it doesn't make any sense right you've
got to you've got to you've got to die
or else you're going to
die that's the straight-faced argument
that the libs are making here stop
breathing or else you will die and of
course that is the case all Pagan
religion ultimately comes down to this
all Pagan religion ultimately comes down
to Human Sacrifice because all Pagan
religion ultimately leads to demons and
demons hate you and want to kill you
listen not everyone's ready to hear that
story even
though wise people have understood that
since since the dawn of time virtually
everywhere on Earth so it's not you know
it sounds absurd by today's modern
scientific standards but we live in
absurd times so it's no surprise we live
in times where the brilliant people in
the white lab coats who supposedly know
all the mysteries of the universe are
the ones who tell us that the way to
save the world is for you to stop
breathing okay we live in we live in
times when the Geniuses and the white
lab codes tell you that the way to stop
catching an Airborne illness is to put a
hanky on your face and stand 6 feet away
all right we we live in times when the
Geniuses in the white lab Coates say
that if your your little boy puts on a
tutu ever because you you encouraged him
to then you got to castrate him and chop
his genitals off okay and you've got to
you've got to take an experimental shot
that is going to stop you from catching
a virus and spreading a virus and
actually it doesn't do either of those
things but get 10 more shots because
it'll work next time we promise you okay
we live in an
age of
absurdity and maybe the gods of the copy
book headings were right maybe maybe
there there isn't all that much new
Under the Sun including the sun religion
maybe that's that's the same old Sun
religion that has been has been used to
sacrifice human beings and diminish us
for all of history the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code NES canw check
out for 2 months free on all annual
[Music]
plans